In Surabaya, Indonesia, you can often see people walking to their local bus stop,...
...carrying bags of plastic trash.
That's because at local bus stations, that trash can be exchanged for bus tickets.
We can reduce trash so it doesn't pile up at home...
...because we just can bring it here and make good use of it.
It's a win-win situation.
Here's how the system works.
Ten plastic cups or five plastic bottles are good for a two-hour bus ticket.
It doesn't seem like a lot, but the plastic piles up quickly,...
...and every bit helps because Indonesia, as a whole, has a big plastic problem.
Indonesia is one of the biggest contributors in the world for plastic waste...
...and through this initiative, we hope to raise public awareness on the environment,...
...especially issues that relate to plastic trash.
All this waste is then separated and auctioned off to recycling companies.
The Plastic for Tickets plan is part of an ambitious nationwide initiative...
...called Zero Waste Indonesia 2020.
Kevin Enochs, VOA News.